en este vídeo vamos a ver con más
detalle el clasificar diferentes tipos
de bienes pero antes de ello vamos a ver
algunas definiciones la primera
definición es la de un bien rival una
forma de pensar en ello es que cuando
una persona usa este recurso va a evitar
que otra persona pueda usarlo o va a
impedir la habilidad de que otra persona
lo pueda usar si una persona lo usa
evita o a veces impide que otra persona
lo use o obtenga un beneficio y vamos a
hablar de bienes que son rivales en
comparación con bienes que no son
rivales otra idea relacionada es la
exclusión a veces estas ideas van juntas
pero otras veces no así que excluyente
es que se puede evitar que alguien lo
use los podemos excluir ahora vamos a
hacer un tipo de matriz en donde
pondremos en un eje si algo es un bien
rivalizado o no y en el otro eje si algo
es un bien excluyente o no voy a dibujar
una matriz de dos por dos aquí hago el
rectángulo y pongo dos columnas y dos
renglones
voy a poner si algo es un bien
rivalizado o no bien rival en este
renglón si es un bien rivalizado y en
este otro renglón no es un bien rival y
para las columnas pensaremos si algo es
excluyente o no excluyente si o no
comenzamos en el cuadro de arriba a la
izquierda que ejemplos podemos imaginar
de bienes que sean tanto rivales como
excluyentes pausa en el vídeo y piensen
en ello de hecho muchas de las cosas que
imaginamos comprar o usar caen en esta
categoría son cosas como plátanos sin
duda son excluyentes porque puedo evitar
que alguien tome mi plátano tienes que
pagar para tener el plátano es un bien
rival porque si me como ese plátano
definitivamente voy a impedir que
alguien más tenga acceso a ese plátano
otro ejemplo sería la ropa también es un
bien rival porque si yo uso una camisa
va a ser muy difícil que alguien más la
pueda usar también y como los plátanos
tienes que pagar dinero por esa ropa
difícilmente se puede conseguir ropa
gratis podemos pensar en la vivienda
podemos excluir a alguien de nuestra
vivienda o hacer que pague por ella como
él paga la renta es un bien rival pues
cuando una familia está ocupando esa
vivienda
definitivamente impide que alguien más
ocupe esa vivienda en general los bienes
que están en este cuadrante se llaman
bienes privados ahora imaginemos bienes
que sean excluyentes pero que quizá no
sean rivales y hay un amplio espectro de
cosas que veremos en futuros vídeos y
que no queda claro si caen en esta
categoría o que dependen del contexto
que estemos usando pero un ejemplo de
algo que es excluyente pero no
necesariamente un bien rival o sea el
que una persona lo use no evita
necesariamente que lo use otra persona
al menos en teoría es la televisión
satelital porque es excluyente porque se
puede hacer que alguien pague por tener
televisión satelital ya que solamente se
puede ver la señal si se tiene cierto
tipo de dispositivo y un código pero la
razón por la que es un bien no rival es
porque el satélite que se encuentra en
el espacio está transmitiendo la señal a
la tierra
y en teoría si yo estoy aquí recibiendo
televisión satelital no va a evitar que
alguien más en otro lugar reciba también
televisión satelital hemos hecho que
esté bien sea escaso de forma artificial
haciendo que la gente pague por ello
aunque el que uno tenga acceso a él no
impide que otros también tengan acceso
es por eso que a esta categoría se le
conoce como bienes escasos
artificialmente la escasez se provoca
artificialmente por hacerlos excluyentes
pero no tienen que hacerlo
necesariamente otro ejemplo puede ser un
parque privado si compro mucho terreno y
le arreglo el paisaje podría decir que
tienen que pagar mil pesos para poder
entrar a ese parque sin duda se volvería
algo muy exclusivo ya que se excluiría a
las personas de ese parque pero en
teoría si ese parque suficientemente
grande si yo entro a ese parque eso no
impide necesariamente que alguien más
también pueda disfrutar del parque si en
cierto momento miles o millones de
personas quisieran entrar a ese parque
al mismo tiempo entonces si podría
volverse un bien riva
ahora veamos la otra columna las cosas
que no son excluyentes si pensamos en un
bien rival pero no excluyente el ejemplo
clásico son los estanques de peces nos
referimos a un cuerpo de agua en donde
hay varios peces y no se puede excluir a
las personas de este cuerpo de agua las
personas pueden acercarse a este
estanque con sus cañas de pescar y
atrapar a algunos peces pero el problema
está en que si yo atrapo un pez entonces
va a ser más difícil que otra persona
atrape un pez pueden imaginarse el
extremo de que si hay muchas personas
atrapando peces eso evitará que otras
personas puedan atraparlos este tipo de
recurso o de bien se conoce como recurso
común y esto tiende a algo que se llama
la tragedia de los comunes y del que
tenemos un vídeo al respecto la tragedia
de los comunes que le ocurre a los
recursos comunes es que cuando todas las
personas actúan en su beneficio personal
es decir que cada quien atrapa tantos
peces como puede ya sea para ellos para
sus familias y para venderlos al final
esto resulta en algo que no es para él
y tampoco para el interés personal a
largo plazo el que muchas personas se
beneficien de esto a corto plazo puede
hacer que disminuyan tanto a los peces
que no queden los suficientes para
reproducirse de manera que a mediano o
largo plazo se acaben por completo los
peces en ese estanque perjudicando a
todos
incluyéndose a uno mismo esa es la
tragedia de los comunes esto es algo
típico que ocurre con los recursos
comunes otra cosa que podemos ver como
recurso común es la madera que está en
la tierra y que todos pueden acceder a
ella así como el agua limpia y fresca si
muchas personas tienen acceso a estos
recursos podrían volverse rivaliza 2
pero si hay pocas personas que acceden a
esta y el agua fresca es mucha se vuelve
menos rivalizado esto se puede debatir
dependiendo de las circunstancias por
último pero no menos importante
pensemos en ejemplos de bienes que se
consideran no rival ni excluyentes esta
categoría se refiere a los bienes
públicos pausa en el vídeo y vean si
pueden pensar en alguno una cosa que se
considera un bien público
aunque se puede debatir en cierto
extremo si el aire se acabará comenzaría
a percibirse como un bien rival pero en
la mayoría de los casos si una persona
respira aire no disminuye la habilidad
de que otra persona también respire aire
y es muy difícil evitar que alguien
respire todos tenemos que hacerlo es por
eso que se considera un bien público
podemos imaginar algo como la defensa
nacional
si nos beneficiamos de la defensa
nacional debido a los tanques
portaaviones fuerza aérea sistema de
misiles y todo lo que tiene la nación
esto impide que mi vecino también se
beneficie de ello pues no de hecho sería
muy difícil el excluir a alguien de este
país del beneficio de la defensa
nacional así que en general se considera
no excluyente el que alguien se sienta
seguro al pensar en la defensa nacional
eso no disminuye mi habilidad de
sentirme seguro también al pensar en la
defensa nacional así que tampoco es un
bien rival por lo que lo consideramos
como un bien público cuando hablamos de
los bienes públicos también está la
noción del problema del policía
y se debe a que como no se puede excluir
a las personas de usarlo no hay
motivación para que algún emprendedor se
haga cargo de estos recursos por lo que
cae en el dominio del gobierno y si
pensamos en toda esta columna de los no
excluyentes este es el dominio de las
cosas en las que se involucra el
gobierno en donde establecen
regulaciones o permisos para evitar la
tragedia de los comunes con el estanque
de peces o con la madera o con el agua
fresca